Scary fun was the motto for one of
the startups I worked for back in the day.
Many who choose to create and
build organizations can
surely relate to this idea.
Hello, I'm Matt Abrahams, and
I teach Strategic Communication at
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
Welcome to Think Fast,
Talk Smart, The Podcast.
I am incredibly excited and
honored today to chat with Steve Blank.
Steve is an adjunct professor at Stanford
in the Department of Management, Science,
and Engineering.
He teaches courses on lean startups,
innovation, and entrepreneurship.
He is credited with launching
the Lean startup movement, and
he's the author of
The Four Steps to the Epiphany,
The Startup Owner's Manual,
and Holding a Cat by its Tail.
Welcome, Steve.
>> Thanks for having me, Matt.
>> You've been an entrepreneur for
over 45 years,
founding or co-founding eight businesses
and helping countless others.
You mentioned this lean startup
methodology, can you summarize that
approach and what it looks like and what
are some best practices included in it?
>> Well, Matt, that's usually a semester
class, but I'll try to do it.
[LAUGH] Don't cut me off.
>> Right, we'll take the cliffnotes
version, if you don't mind.
>> The cliffnotes version basically says,
and it's so obvious it's like duh,
but we didn't quite process it,
is that there are no facts inside your
building, so get the heck outside.
>> Right?
>> And what I mean by that is,
if you remember, what I said is startups
used to believe it's all they needed to do
is write a plan and raise some money and
now execute for the plan.
Why?
Because if the plan was funded, well,
VCs and God have blessed that plan.
Those aren't hypotheses,
those are facts, right?
People give you money for
them, so let's go build it.
The lean method simply says, look,
you have a set of hypotheses.
It's okay, you're out there on day one,
a start up is a faith-based enterprise.
But we want to turn it into
facts as rapidly as possible.
And no facts exist inside your building,
or very few.
And if you're in sales or marketing,
it's impossible to be smarter than the
collective intelligence of your potential
customers sitting in your building.
So let's go out and test these hypotheses.
So piece one of the lean startup is
a formal methodology called customer
development.
Let's go do these things to
validate who are the customers,
what features do they want, [INAUDIBLE]
do they want, competitors, etc.
But while we're doing that, something
else evolved in the 21st century.
And that's the way to build products
using something called Agile engineering.
That is, let's build products
iteratively and incrementally,
rather than using a waterfall method,
which is a write this spec,
build the product, go through alpha test,
beta test, first customership.
If you use Agile instead, you could
be building wireframes, or tests, or
spreadsheets, or something to put in
front of customers very early on,
or potential customers,
and get their feedback.
And then take that back and
say, well, wait a minute,
were the assumptions correct?
So Agile engineering is part
two of the lean startup.
And then finally,
what hypotheses should you be testing?
I just mentioned some of them,
it turns out that someone named
Alexander Osterwalder had put together
something called
the Business Model Canvas.
And that's a pretty good roadmap of the
nine things you need to worry about when
you're building a new venture.
Not all of them, but
it gets about 80 to 90%.
Now, in fact, Lean is those three
components, customer development,
agile engineering, and
business model design.
>> That was an amazing crash course,
thank you.
>> You got the whole semester.
>> There we go.
>> Nobody needs to take my class.
>> I was just going to say, send me
the final exam, I'm ready to graduate.
I like the way you package that up.
And faith to fact, I think, is a really
interesting way to think about it.
Generating hypotheses, testing them with
people who actually might want to buy your
product, what a brilliant idea.
And then this notion of rapid iteration
and prototyping, critical as well.
I have a hypothesis I'd
like to run by you.
So part of what you discussed as
the lean methodology is this notion of
minimally viable product design where
you test for user requirements,
you understand, at least have
some hypotheses about the market,
come up with some wireframes,
and then test and iterate.
I feel that same process can apply
to our communication as well.
It's about, as you said,
understanding your audience.
It's about understanding the context in
which the messages need to be created and
deployed.
It's about structuring those messages,
much like you would build
a wireframe of a product or service.
And then you iterate and test.
Does the concept of minimally viable
communication resonate with you at all?
>> I think that's a key tenet
of everything I teach you about
communications.
For a startup, and I don't mean to diss
on these folks, but hiring a PR agency
too early is a sign that the CEO is
treating this as someone else's problem.
For me, in a startup, the first task,
the minimum viable product of
understanding audience message,
media and messenger can only be done
with the founders and CEO engaged.
That is, even if they think they know
nothing about any of this stuff,
I want them to actually get out of
the building and figure this out, why?
Because they'll get it wrong and whatever,
but they'll have a fingertip feel now of,
this is our stake in the ground, now let's
hire professionals who could do this.
But we've built our own MVPs with,
in fact,
the people who best know the product and
think they know the rest of these things.
It makes a much better
relationship with a agency and
the founders, who typically never get
engaged in this part of the business,
to actually have to have
done it themselves.
And I don't mean six months of this, but
I mean a couple of weeks of
trying to figure this out.
I make them draft those audience message
messengers and media draft themselves.
And then when they're interviewing
an agency, they could say, well,
this is what we found.
Tell us what's wrong, or
how do we do this better?
And usually good agencies
could add huge value here, but
at least they're talking to an educated
founding team who appreciates what
the language means and the value.
>> Excellent, so
getting your hands dirty as a founder and
really understanding the impact and
importance of that communication can serve
you well when you then go get professional
help to help move things forward.
>> And let me double down why.
Because smart CEOs treat
communications as a force multiplier,
a tool to dramatically increase sales or
valuation, or
the vehicles to get acquired
lined up at the door.
Not so successful CEOs treat it as
a tactic that could be handed to others.
And that's the difference for
me about where marketing and
marketing communications needs to
sit in the early days of a company.
If the founders never been engage,
you're never going to get
high quality communications.
And I think the canonical or
the pinnacle of this was Steve Jobs.
He was engaged.
This to him wasn't some other thing
that you handed to someone else,
he was constantly engaged,
and Apple had some of the most brilliant
marketing of the 20th and 21st century.
>> Absolutely, and
it still reverberates today.
I'd like to dig a little deeper
into the role of communication.
And how have you seen communication
played not just in marketing and
selling of products and ideas, but within
organizations in terms of teams, etc.
What best practices or advice and guidance
have you seen that can really make
a difference with regard to communication?
>> Boy, do we have another semester?
I mean, [LAUGH] stop me
when we run out of airtime.
But let me start with, even today, people
tend to make the same mistakes about
marketing and communication in startups
as I did when I was a young entrepreneur.
Number one is they often
confuse communications tactics.
What should my webpage look like,
or should I be using Facebook or
Instagram, with a strategy.
A communication strategy, at least for
me, answers a couple questions.
Why are we doing these activities?
For example, and I'll give you four
examples, these happen to be my four, but
we could make us some others is,
is there a communication strategy designed
to create demand for our products and
drive them into a sales channel?
And are we trying to create awareness
of our company and brand for
potential customers, are we try to
educate and position the company?
Are we trying to create awareness for
fundraising?
That is, gee, we're out raising money and
we're hoping that we could get
the attention of some folks.
Or do we want to create awareness for
potential acquirers?
So once you figured out the why
you're creating this strategy,
I just gave you a list of mine.
And then you need to figure out the how.
There's just four steps.
One is understand your audience.
Number two is, what's the message for
that specific audience?
So we got audience and we got message.
Three is, what's the media you want the
message to be read or seen or heard on?
And then four is, who's the messenger
you want to carry your message?
>> I think that's really, really helpful
to break it down into those ways.
There's a very simple model of
communication that I will teach, and
others, that looks at those elements.
It's you have a sender, and who is
that sender and who's the best sender?
What's the message?
What's the appropriate channel?
And what can you do to make the likelihood
that your message will resonate
the most with the receiver?
And I hear you talking about all
of those elements, for sure.
>> With one addition, and the one addition
I start with is, so who's the audience?
Because in a startup, there's multiple
audiences typically in your head.
Do I want to reach the customers,
or do I want to reach VCs, or
do I want to reach other companies?
And what's confusing is,
when you're trying to figure this out,
the way I tend to say, well, timeout,
let's go back to our strategy.
Are we trying to reach customers or
investors or acquirers?
And they're very different audiences with
each requiring their own message media and
messengers.
And if you try to kind of put them
together, you end up with a ball of twine.
So how do you figure out which one of
these are most important in what order?
It turns out, if you remember,
we talked about the business model.
If you drill down on it, you kind of
understood that there are typically
multiple customer segments, each one
of them who have their own pains that
they want solved or
are looking for solution.
VCs are looking for
hot deals in this area.
Corporate customers might be looking for
something very specific.
And so to figure out who the audience is,
you need to go back,
all the way to the back, to what's our
strategy and what's our business model?
The second part is, what's the message?
I tend to think that messages
answer three questions.
Why should the audience care?
What are you offering?
And more importantly,
what's the call to action?
The last one is to me the most important,
it's like, okay,
what do you want them to do?
You want to pick up the phone, or
click here, or do something else?
Or are you just trying to kind of get into
their heads and you could own a space?
Now what's nice is if you've been doing
some of this customer development that's
getting out in the building, this is a big
idea is that your customers have already
told you how to craft the first
part of the message, that is,
why they should care.
That comes directly from the, if you've
done customer development correctly,
they've told you what their pains and
gains are.
If you haven't done any of this getting
out of the building, then you're staring
at a blank sheet of paper going,
I wonder what they care about.
>> Many things you've said are absolutely
critical to all types of communication.
You have to know your audience.
You have to understand
what's relevant to them.
Then you have to craft
messages that are tailored
to that audience that are in
service of the broader strategy.
And one key point that I really want to
echo for everybody to really internalize
is, you have to adjust and
adapt the message for that audience.
It is so often that people try to create
one pitch deck or one message and
then spread it among multiple audiences.
And that's where you dilute the message,
and
you can actually confuse
the people you're talking to.
So that point you made,
all the points were valuable, but
that one in particular
I wanted to highlight.
>> There's a couple more things about the
message that I run into all the time, but
particularly entrepreneurs coming out of a
technical world, is what are you offering?
And almost always they
start with a feature list.
Here are all the bullets, and
here's why we're doing X or Y.
And I just kind of shut them down.
I go, wait a minute, if we've gotten out
of the building and talked to customers,
we should know what's important to them.
It's not the feature list, but what
relieves pain or creates gain for them.
And again, if you've just sitting in
the building staring at a blank sheet
of paper, you're not going to have a clue.
But if you've talked to them,
you would have known it.
And then finally, the call to action.
As I said, what do you want them to do?
The other thing is context for messages.
A message that's brilliant today might be
met with blank stares two years ago or
two years from now.
So remember that all
messages operate in context,
that it sometimes have an expiration date.
And then finally, messages need to be
memorable, they need to be sticky.
Because the more memorable the message,
the greater its ability to create change.
The classic analogy is, consider if you
were told you were going to pay for
cold dead fish wrapped in seaweed,
you might not be too hungry.
But when we call it sushi,
people line up and pay lots of money.
So that's enough about message.
Matt, back to you.
>> When I'm hearing you say about
messages are so many valuable things.
One, it has to be tailored to
an audience and their specific needs.
Second, it should not just
be a list of features,
it needs to be value and relevance.
Bullets kill, don't kill your
audience with bullet points.
You must consider the context as well, and
the context in which the message is
delivered can change dramatically.
And then finally, your last point was we
need to make it memorable so it sticks.
And that has to do with not only
relevance, but the words you use,
the framing you use, etc.
All of that is such valuable advice,
thank you.
>> And Matt, the last two points,
go back were media messengers.
Media today, when I was an entrepreneur,
we used to cut down dead trees and
put ink on them,
people used to have antennas on
their roofs and watch broadcast TV.
Today we just kind of think of social
media, but you need to have a media mix.
It's likely that each audience
reads different media,
potential customers read something
different then potential investors.
You need to have a media strategy, and
that's a plan that describes the mix
of media and how you use it.
And by the way, the media to me also
includes your website, your Facebook page,
your Twitter page, etc.
It should be the first place that you
experiment finding your audience and
messengers.
And then the last part is, messengers,
and these are kind of the well placed and
highly leveraged individuals
who influence your audience.
And I'm not talking about your CEO,
I'm talking about who's respected
in that industry that now you've actually
given them your PowerPoint slide and
they they're using it
to diagram the space.
Messengers are the one who convey and
amplify your message to your audience
through the media you've chosen.
And so some types of messengers, for
example, are reporters, industry experts,
evangelists, connectors, and each audience
has their own unique set of messengers.
And some of them nowadays, social
media can be bought, like influencers.
So you could actually pay for
some messengers as well.
And depending on your industry and
what you're trying to achieve,
messengers will vary very wildly,
>> Very useful reminders there that your
communication is not just the messages
that you create, it's the media and
channels through which you release them.
And it's the messengers who act on your
behalf to amplify and spread them, very,
very important.
So before we end,
I'd like to ask you the same three
questions I ask everyone who joins me.
You okay with that?
>> Sure.
>> All right, here we go.
If you were to capture the best
communication advice you ever received
as a five to seven word presentation
slide title, what would it be?
>> Well, it's the one I kind of lived on,
is any idiot can make a complicated thing
sound complicated, it takes real
skill to make it sound simple.
>> So it takes real skill to make
something sound simple, absolutely.
We've spent a lot of time on this podcast
with many guests talking about how to make
complex information
accessible to an audience.
So it's not about dumbing it down,
it's about making it relevant and
putting it in into terms
that people can understand.
Let me ask you question number two,
who is a communicator that you admire and
why
>> The individual communicator, obviously,
again, I grew up in a world of
the 20th century Steve Jobs and
the 21st century Steve Jobs.
Probably the best in my mind about being
able to create a reality distortion field
that made you want to throw out
a perfectly good product every year and
buy the next one.
Steve Jobs reinvented the 20th
century automobile model change.
It used to be in the 50s and
60s people would stand in line to
see the next year's car model,
hard to believe now, and
actually buy it because it had
bigger tail fins or flashier chrome.
Steve Jobs essentially resurrected that
idea and managed to convince people that
the last year's iPhone that they
loved is completely obsolete, but
you should still love the company,
because this one has a flashier feature.
The phrase was planned obsolescence.
And at the same time, obviously, was able
to communicate the benefits of new product
breakthroughs like iPod and
iPhone and etc.
>> Final question,
what are the first three ingredients that
go into a successful communication recipe?
>> I mentioned kind of the audience
message or message, etc.
But I guess I would tell you
it's something different,
to kind of just put a cap on it.
If the CEO thinks this is a tactic,
there isn't going to be
a successful communication recipe.
If the CEO thinks it's a strategy,
an integral and a force multiplier for
the company, then there's going to be
a successful communication strategy and
recipe.
>> Right, so it's really the investment
and focus on communication.
So many entrepreneurs see
communication as a necessary evil,
rather than as something that really needs
to have some deep strategy behind it.
Thank you so much.
Your insights, perspectives, and passion
are incredibly helpful and motivational.
I've thoroughly enjoyed our time together,
and
all of us have learned
a lot from your experience.
Thank you.
>> Well, thank you, Matt, I learned a lot,
actually, when you asked the question.
>> Well, excellent, thank you.
[MUSIC]
Thanks for joining us for another episode
of Think Fast, Talk Smart, The Podcast.
Produced by Stanford University's
Graduate School of Business.
For more information and
episodes, visit gsb.stanford.edu.
Or subscribe to our show
wherever you get your podcasts.